number of nfl players are opting out of
the upcoming
2020 football season because of
coronavirus concerns
new england patriot safety patrick chung
is a three-time super bowl champion
he is one of six players on the team
who've chosen to sit out this season
only on cbs this morning he joins us to
discuss
his decision and recommendations for the
league we'd like to note we did reach
out to the nfl
and they told us they are not issuing a
statement at this time on
the opt-outs good morning patrick thank
you so much for joining us
first and foremost was this a tough
decision
and why do it
uh i mean of course a stealth decision
you know you want to play football you
know
i'm in the latter end of my career so
you know i want to i wanted to play
football but
when it comes down to it i feel just
money is not that important you know my
family i have a
a girlfriend that's pregnant coming
coming baby girl coming soon my son has
a little asthma
my dad you know he's 75 years old so
i just felt like this was the best
decision you know for my family to
you know keep everyone safe you know i
don't think it's it's fair to them you
know so i just decided to do that and
you know just it's not over it's just
postponed a little bit
it sounds like there wasn't necessarily
been anything that the league could have
done
differently to make you change your mind
um no it has nothing to do with i had
nothing to delete with the league i mean
we had
no idea you know this um kovit was
coming you know and so it has
the league they're they're doing their
precautions trying to do it to keep
people safe so it's nothing with the
league it's just more about
you know people have different
situations you know and different
families you know i just happen to have
a certain situation where i had to make
the you know the best decision for my
family
and you know that's that's that's what i
did what was that conversation like with
coach bill belichick when you told him
that you weren't
going to be playing this season
i mean that's private but he he
understood i would say
he understood he understands that you
know it's a serious
pandemic you know going on and then you
know he
totally he totally got it you know bill
you got you guys think bill is like
this drill sergeant but he's actually
he's actually a very caring person you
know so he totally understood and
you know that was it it was a short
phone call
in terms of the other players that
you've spoken to we know that there have
been six do you expect more
to opt out
um i mean i don't know i can't really
speak on those guys you know i know i
know a lot of guys are thinking you know
it is it's a scary situation you know
and and
you know whatever they decide then
that's on them i don't i can't really
speak for them but
you know like i said everyone has just
different situations you know some
people don't have
people at high risk in their in their
household or
you know around them you know so it's a
little different you know so
i mean hopefully whenever whatever they
do they make the right decision
that's going to keep their family
healthy keep them healthy
and you know be safe you know so i mean
we'll see that's going to come out you
know eventually
a couple more days and we know already
it's been sort of a modified season
but you know roger goodell came out
earlier this week with a letter to fans
saying even the best game
plan changes as new challenges arise do
you expect to see a full nfl season
things are consistently and continue to
change when it comes to this virus
i mean i i pray so you know that that
only means that you know the
this corona stuff is just getting better
so i i pray there is
you know but i mean as of right now i
mean it's still
it's still a dangerous thing you know so
i don't really know
i i i hope there is you know for the
sake of the fans and then
people to be able to take care of their
families you know other you know young
players and everything so
but i mean we'll see i mean if it gets
if it gets worse then
you know i don't see it happening you
know it's it's about safety
so but as of right now i i guess it's
kind of
it's okay i mean hopefully it gets
better and the season can go so
i mean only time will tell i want to ask
you about
just how the social and justice uh
sort of movement if you will is taking
shape and the change within the nfl to
hear
roger goodell admit that the league was
wrong on how it handled the
players kneeling what are your thoughts
on that i mean you've been in the league
uh 12 years now
yeah i mean i'm going to keep it you
know i literally
i'm not going to go into all this
political stuff but i mean
it does it's frustrating i mean to see
it and it's very disheartening because
where i come from i'm from jamaica you
know and we don't have the
the race you know all that you're white
black
asian pink purple like you're jamaican
you know so i've never really
truly experienced something like this
you know so it was very it's very new to
me i started hearing you know
the n-word when i came here i didn't i
never heard that you know so
growing up i've always been you know in
jamaica
it's all about how you how you act and
how you carry yourself and that's what
really
defines a person you know so but being
here and learning everything
and seeing it i mean it does suck it's a
little
it's it's a little frustrating it's
disheartening to see that you know
people get judged for
you know their skin color you know we
all have one life you know i don't want
it's it's it's it sucks to take a life
you know you don't wouldn't want someone
to take your life you want someone
someone to treat you a certain way like
that we greatly appreciate we greatly
appreciate you giving us
uh your insight and good luck to you and
your family hopefully you all stay safe
patrick chung thank you so much we'll be
right back